A deadly camping trip, a green dude's
big break, and a super hero movie that
left everyone in tears. 2022’s the year
for sci-fi movies that’ll make you laugh,
cry, and question your existence all at once.
"Prey," the latest installment in the
"Predator" franchise, goes back to 1719,
when one of the first Predators comes to
Earth. This hunter is pitted against Naru,
a Comanche woman looking to prove she
has what it takes to be a great hunter.
"Prey" has breathtaking vistas, bloody
action, and excellent performances. A
tease in the credits and Easter eggs from other
"Predator" films will please franchise fans,
but the biggest reason to see this sci-fi
gem is definitely Amber Midthunder's Naru,
who uses her wits and training against
an alien foe far larger than she.
"Beyond the Infinite Two Minutes" is a
delight from start to finish. Kato lives
upstairs from the café he owns, and one
evening, he discovers a time anomaly while
looking at his computer monitor, allowing
him to see two minutes into the future.
Once his friends find out, they want to see if
they can expand the anomaly to take advantage of
the ensuing foreknowledge, and things spiral from
there. The recursive nature of the repeating two
minutes leads to some philosophical debates,
but "Beyond the Infinite Two Minutes" never
gets too heavy. It's light and breezy — even
when danger looms — and a whole lot of fun.
"Show them who we are."
The sequel to "Black Panther," and
the 30th movie overall in the MCU,
introduces a second incredibly powerful
and hidden nation to the MCU with Talokan.
Talokan is the cinematic update of Atlantis,
home of the submariner Namor who doesn't want
the outside world to discover his homeland
for fear that imperial powers will attack
and steal their resources. But things aren't that
simple — Namor also demands the life of the young
scientist who unintentionally allowed one of
Talokan's vibranium deposits to be discovered,
leading his country into conflict with Wakanda.
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" is a major-scale
movie even for the planet-hopping franchise. Its
international conflict creates a plot that feels
like a political thriller with global stakes,
and its action scenes are some of the most
exciting we've ever seen in the MCU. Of course,
the main thrust of the movie deals with honoring
the legacy of the late Chadwick Boseman and his
character, King T'Challa, and by the end of the
film, there isn't a dry eye in the audience.
"Something in the Dirt" has a deceptively
small scale for its big ideas. The movie
centers on two neighbors who meet shortly after
one of them moves into an apartment building.
They quickly develop a friendship, and when
strange things start happening in the newly
leased apartment — like things floating
inexplicably and wild light refractions
that create patterns on the wall — they decide
to make a documentary about the phenomena. But
as they continue to explore what may be causing
these strange occurrences, they begin to split in
their theories and the methods they want to employ
until we're left with more questions than answers.
"Something in the Dirt" is a fascinating movie not
only for the questions it poses in its plot but
also because it's a strange mix of mockumentary,
home-video collage, and straightforward narrative
that makes it one of the most formally
inventive science fiction movies of the year.
Maika Monroe is a genre darling for a reason,
and this year she's offered us not one,
but two great new genre movies. "Watcher"
delivered a skin-crawling story of a stalker,
and "Significant Other" brings
us a high-concept sci-fi movie.
"Significant Other" follows couple Ruth
and Harry on a backpacking trip in the
Pacific Northwest where they discover a series of
strange and disturbing occurrences
in the wake of a comet's arrival.
The movie doesn't offer answers for a while and
instead keeps the audience guessing in an equally
fun and unnerving game of "what's really going on
here?" It also helps that Monroe and costar Jake
Lacy are giving incredibly charming performances
and that the forest setting is beautiful.
The "Dragon Ball" franchise
has always been about aliens,
as the central Saiyan characters came to
Earth from a different world. But "Dragon Ball
Super: Super Hero" is one of the most science
fiction heavy movies in the franchise as it
focuses not only on aliens but also androids
and a genetically altered "bio-android."
The plot follows the often sidelined
character Piccolo as he takes center
stage in investigating the
resurgent Red Ribbon Army,
a potential threat to the franchise's ensemble
and the world. Like all "Dragon Ball" media,
the movie includes some incredibly exciting
and visually stunning animated fight sequences,
but its focus on Piccolo allows for a new
character to be the emotional center of the film.
From the creative minds that brought us "Free
Guy," "The Adam Project" follows the titular Adam,
a time-traveling pilot from 2050 who
gets stranded in 2022 while pursuing
an unauthorized mission. There, he meets his
12-year-old self, and the two Adams must work
together to accomplish older Adam's objective:
Get back to 2018 to save his wife's life.
But time travel has a way of making things
complicated — especially since older Adam is
fleeing a dystopian future. With
the odds stacked against them,
Big Adam and Little Adam decide
their only solution is to find the
man who actually created time travel
itself ... their dearly departed dad.
"The Adam Project" makes maximum
use of Ryan Reynolds' likability as
older Adam. He plays excellently off
his younger self's vulnerabilities;
newcomer Walker Scobell kills his role.
"God, it's like I traded my brain
for those muscles. It's a s—t deal."
Plus, there are time jets, and both Reynolds and
Mark Ruffalo. Who doesn't want to see
Deadpool interact with Bruce Banner?
"After Yang" is a deeply moving exploration of
memory and grief. In an idyllic-looking future,
parents Jake and Kyra have provided
their adopted daughter Mika with an
android sibling named Yang. When Yang
stops functioning, Jake promises Mika
he will have her "brother" back
to normal as soon as possible.
But as they go through Yang's memory bank,
Jake and Kyra make several major discoveries
about Yang's past and the true depths of his
soul. What emerges is breathtaking, emotional,
and profound — proving filmmaker Kogonada is
one of the very best directors working today.
Writer-director Richard Linklater
mixes fact and fantasy in "Apollo 10 ½:
A Space Age Childhood." A kid
growing up in 1960s Houston,
young Stanley is fired up by Apollo
11. As he watches history unfold,
the real details of the mission are interwoven
with his elaborate dream of being recruited as
an astronaut, because he's small enough to
fit into a lunar module's tight quarters.
"Apollo 10 ½: A Space Age Childhood"
embraces nostalgia without completely
ignoring the upheaval in America
at this time: Houston is just as
fascinating as the moon. The movie uses
rotoscoping, a unique animation technique,
to capture Stanley's imagination just as
vividly as the actual launch of the Saturn V.
Lonely teenager Suzu leads another life
in the virtual world known as "U." There,
she's a famous singer named Belle with
charming freckles and flowing pink hair.
After a concert is violently ruined by
a mysterious user known as the Dragon,
Belle sets out to find him. She soon
discovers they both have tragedy in
their real lives — tragedy they need to overcome.
"Belle" features stunning
visuals and real emotional heft,
rooted in the trials and
tribulations of adolescence.
Sam Raimi infuses the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with his trademark horror in "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness." Superhero sorcerer
Stephen Strange must protect America Chavez,
a dimension-hopping teenager, from
someone seeking to steal her powers.
Their flight across the multiverse takes
them to the very limits of existence,
with Strange grappling with his own issues
and growing his own powers by confronting
dark and disturbing versions of himself
across dimensions — both alive and dead.
Plus, Wanda Maximoff emerges as the emotional
core of the film as she struggles with the
harrowing aftermath of "WandaVision."
What results is a blend of terror,
fantasy, and sci-fi you won't soon forget.
Simply put, "Everything Everywhere All
At Once" is one of the best films of the
year. An endlessly inventive and absurdist
delight, it stars Michelle Yeoh as Evelyn,
a middle-aged laundromat owner whose IRS audit
becomes a surreal adventure. The multiverse
is threatened by a fearsome being, and only
Evelyn can save every dimension everywhere.
An eye-popping journey through alternate
universes ensues. Multiple viewings are a
must to catch every detail packed into this
wild, heartfelt, and colorful good time.
Audiences are told upfront that "Lightyear" is the
film that made "Toy Story's"
Andy a Buzz Lightyear fan.
"To infinity…" "And beyond."
We see the titular hero's headstrong insistence
on adventuring solo strand a ship full of his
fellow Space Rangers on a hostile planet. Buzz
winds up working with a crew of lovable misfits,
including his former partner's granddaughter and
an adorable robotic cat named Sox, to make things
right. But can they overcome Zurg, the enigmatic
villain sending waves of robots after them?
"Lightyear" is a gorgeously animated sci-fi
adventure with lots of comedy and heart. It's
at its best when spotlighting the crew's
attempts to figure out their strengths and
when indulging in absolutely incredible
hyperspace sequences. Whether you're
watching it on an IMAX screen or Disney+, this
Pixar tale is sure to entertain and inspire.
"Neptune Frost" is a singular work of
Afrofuturism. It's a sci-fi musical with
an audacious vision that mesmerizes even if, at
times, the story seems elusive. Set in Burundi,
the film follows a coltan miner named Matalusa
and an intersex runaway named Neptune.
At turns impressionistic and poetic, "Neptune
Frost" features characters with symbolic names
such as Memory and Psychology, and it
primarily concerns an anti-colonialist
hacker collective waging technowar against
an oppressive police state seemingly run by
The Authority. When Matalusa and Neptune meet,
it creates a jolt that powers the collective's
technological fight. Be prepared for the visuals
and songs to get stuck in your cerebral cortex.
Horror auteur Jordan Peele succeeds once more with
"Nope," a sci-fi-horror film about
siblings Emerald and OJ Haywood,
horse wranglers to the stars. When a UFO
begins hovering above their ranch, they
decide to catch it on tape — but they're not the
only ones with plans for the mysterious entity.
Reporters, photographers, and a sleazy former
child star all have their own designs. "Nope"
tackles society's exploitation of tragedy,
humanity's relationship with animals,
and the treatment of below-the-line crew
on film sets. This makes for a layered
experience that will have you questioning your
own assumptions from the very edge of your seat.
This surreal sci-fi-rom-com adventure stars
Kentucker Audley as James Preble, a government
agent who audits people's dreams. That's right: In
the future this movie imagines, dreams are taxed.
He soon discovers something more sinister afoot
as he audits Bella, an elderly artist and the
sole occupant of the titular home. Full of bizarre
logic, oddball characters, and striking imagery,
"Strawberry Mansion" is a splendid head-trip
guaranteed to expand your imagination.